le 11 novembre 2018 alain bernier est
victime d'un accident vasculaire
cérébral
pendant sa convalescence il reste à son
domicile s'occupe en faisant des
maquettes
par sécurité il s'abonne au bouton
d'appel et détection de chute de blue
line est à relier à une plateforme
d'appels japy dessus ya une petite lampe
rouge qui ça qui s'allument
donc voilà et à ce moment là moi
j'entends qu'effectivement c'est pris en
compte
tout fonctionne bien il n'y a pas de
problème merci beaucoup au revoir quand
je suis revenu à la maison mes enfants
ne voulaient pas que je reste seule
comme ma femme faisait des courses ou
avait ses activités me laisser seul donc
d'une part pour moi me rassurer elle a
rassuré elle aussi directeur du
développement chez blue line et à xavier
corbin bien faire un bilan avec le
client comme alain tavernier près de
28000 personnes sont abonnés à ce
service d'accompagnement de réconfort et
d'assistance c'est un dispositif qui
s'adresse effectivement à un public qui
risque de chuter ou qui a déjà chuté
mais pas uniquement il faut bien voir
que sur l'ensemble des appels que l'on
reçoit dans 90% des cas on va répondre à
des à des demandes qui sont des demandes
de la vie quotidienne qui n'ont aucun
caractère critique aucun caractère
urgent la technologie est également très
importante pour la sécurisation du
transfert des informations et le
traitement de chaque situation au siège
de blue line et à elancourt des
opératrices sont chargés de prendre les
appels 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
cette entreprise emploie aujourd'hui
près de 80 collaborateurs son activité
proposer des solutions pour les
personnes dépendantes
on voit régulièrement apparaître de
nouvelles solutions de nouveaux objets
je dirais presque parfois de nouveaux
gadgets qui sont plus ou moins
intéressants pour nos marchés
donc pour nous il est vraiment très
important de choisir les bons produits
de développer les bons produits
parce que la technologie est en fait
qu'un moyen de délivrer un service ou de
délivrer une solution autre technologie
proposée le bracelet blue garde destinée
aux personnes atteintes d'alzheimer
on voit l'équipe et de ce bracelet du
blue garde et elle va pouvoir se
déplacer à son gré le bracelet sa
fonction c'est de vérifier en permanence
la personne est bien dans un périmètre
dans une zone de vie prédéfinis et si
elle venait à s'éloigner trop et à
sortir de cette zone de vie
automatiquement nous recevrions une
alerte sur nos plateformes sahara la
société a lancé aussi un nouveau produit
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap
un dispositif pour leur permettre de
jouer à des jeux vidéo